[Musique]
bonsoir à tous bienvenue en point de vue
ravi de vous retrouver pour ce dernier
rendez vous de la semaine autour de
quatre thèmes qu'on va découvrir tout de
suite en image et que nous allons
traiter avec nos invités
toujours pas de repreneur pour la syrie
d'ascq ovale dans le nord peut-on sauver
cette usine et au delà peut-on sauver le
made in france industrielle
on en parlera on parlera aussi de la
visite des manuels macron en république
tchèque et en slovaquie le président
veut-il se réconcilier avec le groupe de
vice grave vous savez ces pays d'europe
de l'est qui n'aiment plus beaucoup
l'europe ou alors au contraire veut-il
les diviser eh bien là aussi on vous
demandera votre point de vue on parlera
aussi des policiers dans les écoles
c'est la nouvelle idée du gouvernement
pour essayer de lutter contre les
violences scolaires mais est ce une
bonne idée
et puis enfin après le bras de fer gagné
par stéphane bern contre bercy pour
avoir plus d'argent pour le patrimoine
d'argent du fameux l'auto inventé par
notre confrère on vous demandera si vous
êtes plutôt berne ou plutôt darmanin
bonsoir maxime dégâts hier soir vous
êtes expert associé à la fondation jean
jaurès ou est aussi conseiller régional
socialiste d'île de france
votre dernier livre la grande des
possessions pour une éthique numérique
européenne a été publié par les éditions
de la fondation jean jaurès
bonsoir guillaume bernard soit vous êtes
maître de conférences à l'iss s
l'institut catholique des études
supérieures je ne me trompe pas c'est en
vendée on est ravi de vous recevoir et
on connaît désormais votre livre la
guerre à droite aura bien lieu
le mouvement dextrogyre publié aux
éditions desclée de brouwer bonsoir
jérôme sainte marie
les politologues sondeurs président
fondateur de la société pôle inbox est
votre dernier livre le nouvel ordre
démocratique a été publié aux éditions
du moment
puis hervé nathan est là aussi bon soir
hervé on souhaite directeur adjoint de
la rédaction de marianne
notre confrère qui
mais en couverture ce week-end cette
semaine deux sujets qu'on va traiter
aujourd'hui la révolte des profs
et puis le made in france qui peut selon
vous sauver la france
et bah on va en parler tout de suite du
moulin et sauvons la france tout de
suite elle ne peut pas attendre
voilà vous savez qu'il ya un bras de fer
autour de lusine asco valls et une à
siri qui est installée à saint saulve
dans le nord 280 emplois sont en jeu
pour l'instant il n'y a pas de repreneur
parce que il pourrait y en avoir un mais
l'actionnaire majoritaire de la société
vallourec refuse de d'assurer des
commandes
alors du coup que faut-il faire et bien
il y en a une qui a une solution assez
radical c'est marine le pen
une seule solution la nationalisation
j'assume la prise de risque c'était
c'est vrai que ce que je propose est une
quasi nationalisation
moi je suis pour la préservation de la
capacité de production et donc vous du
savoir faire et je pense que c'est plus
important que la rentabilité
jérôme sainte-marie j'avais dire quand
on en est là c'est quelque chose qui va
pas si on est obligé de nationaliser une
entreprise en 2018
c'est peut-être dire que l est pas
viable ça peut dire plusieurs choses ça
peut dire soit effectivement qu'elle est
pas viable ou bien que le coût du
travail est trop important en france par
exemple
ça peut être des vouloir dire également
peut-être que les choix macroéconomiques
fait par la france dans le cadre union
européenne ne lui permettent pas de
maintenir son industrie et non seulement
ne permettent pas de maintenir son
industrie mais il ya plus grave
dire que moi je suis très frappé ces
derniers temps par la perte de la franc
pas la france de ce que j'appellerais
l'industrie de souveraineté c'est à dire
vous savez par exemple fait qu'il n'ya
plus qu'une seule
une seule entreprise qui est capable
désormais de fournir l'armée française
en fusils de précision
moi je m'appelle par exemple et c'est
vrai sur toute une série d'industries et
qu'on perd effectivement toute une série
de savoir faire que l'on ne retrouvera
pas et qu'effectivement il ya en effet
quelque chose qui relève de
l'indépendance nationale qui est menacé
aujourd'hui par ces délocalisations une
fois que les entreprises sont partis
c'est pour ça que la nationalisation
peut se justifier
une fois que les entreprises sont partis
c'est tous les savoir-faire des camps
les contrats etc qui partent et on est
quand même devant aussi un problème
enfin le quinquennat a commencé par un
énorme dossier qui est quand même la
perte par la france d'alstom et de
l'ensemble des savoir faire qui était
liée là c'est véritablement des dégâts
qui sont irréversibles c'est pas comme
si c'était comment dirais-je une courbe
un cycle économique c'est parti ça
revient les savoir-faire perdus ne
reviendront pas hervé nathan on peut
comprendre ça pour des industries dites
stratégiques
mais là cette usine fabrique des tubes
en acier alors je sais que c'est la base
d'un fusil mais quand même c'est un peu
plus de technologies dendre que est ce
que c'est si grave
vous savez vous connaissez vous êtes un
journal économique vous connaissez
schumpeter la destruction créatrice
quand une entreprise des plus rentables
et ben on a fermé tant pis oui mais
d'abord il faudrait s'assurer que les
conditions de 2
cette entreprise exerçant de son travail
sont saines on sait par exemple que
l'acier l'acier chinois rentre encore
avec droits de douanes qui ont été
relevés à 25% mais pas à 200 % comme le
font les états unis sur le sur les mêmes
produits
donc déjà on pourrait peut-être se poser
la question est ce que à ce que valve
n'est pas la victime du dumping de du
jumping sur l'acier chinois puisque les
chinois huo d'énormes surplus coeur
capacités' inonde le monde et c'est un
vrai problème que la même la commission
européenne a reconnu d'une vous êtes
levé 2 sur la directio nisme oui bien
sûr non européens certainement et
peut-être même nationale si l'une au
niveau européen ça ne il ya un défaut
parce qu'on peut pas on peut pas à la
fois déploré de voir les territoires
dévastés d'avoir des preuves sociaux
d'avoir des problèmes de jeunesse
d'avoir des problèmes de formation etc
sans se poser la question à un moment
donné comme on stoppe là c'est un stop
la chaux nous on a fait vous l'avez cité
un dossier qui s'intitule comment le
made in france peut sauver la france
parce qu'on pense que l'industrie le
fait de garder sur le territoire d
industrie du disque et souveraineté d'un
demi point de vue aussi des industries
de base comme le textile
et bien c'est à la fois fournir aux
emplois mais c'est aussi fournir de bons
emplois parce que c'est mieux rémunérés
dans l'industrie que dans les services
c'est plus stable pour les jeunes ça
permet de la recherche
on oublie toujours on parle tout le
temps des start up mais les premiers des
laboratoires de recherche de recherche
appliquée c'est d'abord l'automobile le
plus
l'entreprise qui dispose de plus de
brevets en france c'est psa qui est
d'ailleurs on a presque routière fait
donner aux chinois et s'est sauvé
l'industrie
louis s'est sauvé effectivement est un
peu y imprime d'indépendance nationale
il ya un problème de ty de cohérence du
territoire et enfin de cohérence et ça
permet de soigner tout ça merci avait
nathan vous pose la question à sur
twitter faut-il nationaliser la syrie à
ce qu'au val vous êtes une majorité mais
pas écrasante a considéré que non sur le
figaro.fr anti mac lui il a choisi son
camp il dit quelle démagogie chez marine
le pen va t'on nationaliser chaque
entreprise en difficulté amr que
si je te dis quand on a une balance
commerciale aussi mauvaise quand on a
autant de chômage l'industrie doit être
préservée impérativement être ajouter un
détail qui n'en est pas c'est que enfin
vallourec qui refuse de donner des
données 50 millions d'euros de commandes
à son ex-filiale es koval le point
l'actionnaire qui est venu à son secours
c'est la banque publique
d'investissement c'est donc l'état en
est certaine manière ya pas besoin c'est
là où on va contredire marine le pen y a
pas besoin et nationalisé à ce qu'au val
parce qu'en fait il ya besoin que l'état
voilà l'exploit de faire l'état des
actionnaires de vallourec mes
actionnaires mais lloris qui au bernabeu
on a eu une situation assez proche de
celle là c'était l'année dernière avec
une usine qui s'appelait j ai mais
est-ce qu'ils étaient installés à la
souterraine qui fabriquait des produits
pour les voitures et ça se passe dans la
creuse et bruno le maire qui était déjà
ministre de l'économie à l'époque était
allé les voir en disant mais oui j'ai
obtenu de peugeot que de psa que qu'elle
ait un minimum de commande et puis j'ai
regardé le dossier avant de venir
il y avait 25 millions de commandes qui
étaient promises et finalement on n'y
est pas on n'est même pas à la moitié
parce que encore une fois dans une
économie ouverte ne peut pas forcer les
gens à acheter des produits s'ils sont
trop chers oui mais justement on vous
mettre le doigt vous mettez le doigt sur
l'un des soucis essentiel c'est à la
fois la question du coût du travail qui
est différent en fonction des états et
puis des régions et par conséquent il ya
une responsabilité de l'état on vient
d'en parler dans je dirais une forme de
deux demi sur un pied d'égalité de ces
différentes industries
et puis là je suis désolé de dire
revenir mais ça me paraît absolument
essentiel il est important que un pays
est une industrie qui soit sur le plus
large spectre possible pour assurer son
indépendance parce que la division
internationale du travail comme on
disait auparavant la mondialisation
comme on dit aujourd'hui c'est très bien
parce que ça crée une interdépendance
pourquoi pas sacré je dirais des liens
qui peuvent éviter je dirais des
conflits qui pourraient dégénérer mais
ça crée aussi une dépendance des états
et des salariés et de la population
vis-à-vis de firmes transnationales voir
à nationale dont la logique n'est
absolument pas celle de
l'intérêt tu dirais d'un développement
harmonieux du territoire et de la
population mais dont l'intérêt est
exclusivement ou principalement
financier donc je ne sais pas s'il faut
ce que l'état intervienne pour
renationaliser mais en revanche qu'il
crée les conditions pour favoriser le
fait qu'un état est suffisamment de
production dans tous les domaines pour
assurer au minimum une certaine
indépendance et peut-être même une
autosuffisance ça me paraît absolument
nécessaire maxime les gagner je crois
que le problème qui nous est posée c'est
qu' il n'y a pas de stratégie
industrielle aujourd'hui qui nous
permettent de nous réarmer on sait bien
qu'une économie sans industrie c'est une
économie sans gains de productivité au
delà même des questions de souveraineté
nationale
ce dont on souffre aujourd'hui c'est
donc c'est pour ça qu'il faut pas faire
des coups de menton à chaque drame même
si on comprend l'exaspération des
personnes concernées et moi ce que je
note aujourd'hui c'est que il faut agir
à la bonne échelle c'est à faire des
paris industriels aujourd'hui on ne sait
pas quelle est la politique industrielle
que nous menons dans ce pays il n'y a
pas de politique industrielle clairement
affirmée au niveau européen et d'autre
part parce que moi j'ai bien en tête ce
qui s'est passé est que les chantiers de
saint nazaire où pour le coup il ya une
dizaine d'années ils devaient être
fermés aujourd'hui ils ont des bons de
commandes jusqu'en 2026 donc il peut
être possible de pouvoir remettre en
dynamique des industries dans notre pays
mais pour cela il faut penser
l'ensemble de la chaîne c'est-à-dire à
la fois faire des paris industriel
assumer et deuxièmement est en capacité
aussi de forme et on n'en parle pas mais
aujourd'hui on a un vrai problème de
formation dans ce pays et c'est pas la
réforme de l'apprentissage qui supprime
700 cfa qui va nous permettre de pouvoir
préserver nos savoir faire
on voit bien aujourd'hui que l'on
considère que le laisser faire ou la
réduction des coûts devrait finalement
être le dogme et qui nous permettrait de
maintenir notre industrie c'est pas mon
sentiment je crois au contraire qu'il
faut une vraie stratégie et aujourd'hui
on ne souffre de ne pas en avoir c'est
quand même une déception hervé nathan
pour le gouvernement parce que en quand
il a assoupli le code du travail quand
il a continué à baisser les charges sur
les salaires
l'objectif c'était justement d'avoir une
industrie françaises plus compétitives
et quand on a 40 milliards de déficit
commercial ça veut dire que ça marche
mal non il ajouté
et à la fonction prend à la fois ce
gouvernement si le gouvernement
précédent
d'abord ce gouvernement signale a
tellement pas de ce raté indiciels qui a
pas de mini de l'industrie pour la
première fois depuis très longtemps il
ya bunny bni ministre d'industrie nil
ministre des pme dans ce gouvernement et
les secrétaires d'état qui vient d'être
nommé qu'on envoie sur les dossiers
alors fait pompiers là il est en train
de faire prier dans les hauts de france
elle fera peut-être pompiers ailleurs
peut-être je souhaite bon courage quand
il va s'agir de voir les morceaux de
d'alstom qu'on a vendu aux états unis
alors que le groupe le groupe mondial
alstom est en train de péricliter
donc effectivement on aura de nouvelles
pertes d'emplois et de savoir faire
mais voilà les dons qu'il ya une absence
de canton nord mon voisin m'a dit ali à
une absence de stratégie industrielle
oui ça c'est réel et par ailleurs le
cicr a d'abord aidé les entreprises qui
avaient des petits salaires donc des
entreprises du secteur tertiaire
le premier bénéficiaire ça a été la
poste sociaux toujours souvenu de sa le
cic les 20 milliards par m6 et les
baisses des charges dans les charges
basé sachets salaires c'était le plus
que la riposte que l'industrie la poste
carrefour etc
pourquoi parce que dans l'industrie il
ya des salaires relativement élevés les
jeunes comme dans l'industrie quand ils
sont embauchés ils ont un salaire qui à
15 % au-dessus du smic en général plus
stable donc fausse info comprennent pas
ce que c'est surtout pour l'elysée il
faut il que jérôme sainte marie
pour conclure sur ce sujet enfin c'est
pas à ce moment là que l'heure de vérité
mais vous voulez l'impression qui est
très désagréable pour le pouvoir
politique aujourd'hui c'est finalement
le fait de se dire que at-il le moindre
patriotisme économique est effectivement
les promesses de croissance et de
rentabilité accrue de ce qu'on appelait
autrefois le capital est bien est ce que
c'est des quelque chose qui pour lui est
connecté avec la défense de
l'international ce que le général de
gaulle réussissait à faire mais ce qui
aujourd'hui est totalement contraire au
dogme européen antiprotectionnistes que
professe les soutiens sociaux et
politiques des manuels macron donc une
vraie cohérence amont en évidence dans
le fait de ne pas chercher
particulièrement à sauver cette
industrie là ça n'a pas forcément très
rentable pour les pour les groupes en
termes de rentabilité de encore une fois
de bons rendements du capital c'est pas
forcément nécessaire voilà on dit
parfois que le figaro est un journal
trop libérale vous voyez que sur le
plateau de point de vue c'est pas
forcément vrai il ya une forme de
consensus autour de cette table on va
laisser le dernier mot à nos internautes
alors y en a 17
qui sont libéraux comme cameroun eto'o
qui nous dit la france n'a pas un marché
intérieur suffisant pour se permettre de
lancer des mesures protectionnistes et
alors que ni sich lui nous dit dans le
modèle capitaliste libérale actuelle il
faut toujours plus et est dans ces
conditions le marché intérieur ne suffit
pas et puis un dernier mot qui reviendra
à nicole qui nous dit plus que la
fermeture d'une usine
je pense que le plus grave est la perte
des compétences et on en a parlé pendant
ce temps le président macron est en
visite en république tchèque et en
slovaquie alors jusqu'à présent c'était
simple un l'europe il y avait les
gentils
c'étaient les français les allemands et
quelques autres et puis de l'autre côté
les méchants les populistes c'était le
groupe de visegrad vous savez la
tchéquie la slovaquie la pologne et la
hongrie
sauf que là tout a changé désormais
emmanuel macron est ami avec tout le
monde
écoutez le j'entends souvent qu'ils
auraient une division entre l'est et
l'ouest
je n'y crois pas et j'assume des
désaccords avec certains dirigeants
parce que il ne faut pas avoir honte des
valeurs qu'on défend ya pas de bloc des
uns contre les autres
depuis que je suis à cette fonction je
n'ai eu de cesse de discuter avec tout
le monde je me rendrai aussi en pologne
et en hongrie
je me rendrai ça ira mais nathan on est
réconcilié laisse assez de manière
emmanuel macron qui avait été hors is
hell
meules et les modernistes d'un côté et
les populistes et nationalistes contre
les progressistes lui étant progressif
est un peu obligé de mettre de l'eau
dans son vin pour deux raisons la raison
première c'est en tant que gouvernement
peut-être qu'il n'y a pas de majorité
possible sur un certain nombre de
décisions européennes sont divisés le
groupe devise grade
il ya une expérience qui a été heurtée
ces mais réussit d'ailleurs c'est la
révision de la directive sur le travail
des tâches et il a fallu la pluie des
tchèques et des eaux - d'échec si me
souviens bien
pour que cette directive soit adopté par
le conseil européen compte tenu des
majorités contre l'avis des paladins
contre l'avis des polonais donc faut
diviser il peut pas y avoir essayé la
france peut pas se contenter de les
renvoyer comme un bloc elle en a besoin
pour gouverner l'europe en tant que pays
membre de et du conseil européen l'autre
chose c'est qu'il va bientôt y avoir des
élections savent que ce qu'une nul ici
n'ignore autour de cette table dans dans
7 mois et que un moment donné il faudra
bien faire les comptes des amis et des
ennemis il faudra bien que trouver une
majorité dans le futur parlement
européen c'est pas sûr que il n'est pas
besoin de quelques bordures sont là
dessus à droite pour compléter une
majorité cohérente favorables à l'union
européenne
guillaume bernard c'était une impasse
d'opposer comme ça deux europes je crois
que c'était politiquement peut être
extrêmement dix ans mais il me semble
que c'est aussi je dirais
idéologiquement très réducteur faire que
il l'a fait dans un but évidemment
interne
franco français dans le but d'essayer
d'écraser je dirais l'air entre lrm et
puis et puis le front national mais il
n'empêche que au delà de cela il ya des
enjeux idéologiques qui sont réels
c'est-à-dire qu'ils essayent de faire
ami ami avec certains du groupe devise
grade mais peut-être effectivement on
pourrait essayer de s'appuyer sur ceux
qui sont par le fait qu'ils sont
d'anciens pays de l'est plutôt pro
autant que plutôt pro poutine
mais il n'empêche que sur la question
qui va vraisemblablement être la
question centrale des élections
européennes c'est à dire la question des
migrations et la question de l'identité
on a des gouvernements qui sont certes
plus modérée en tchéquie en slovaquie
qu'en pologne ou en hongrie mais qui
sont quand même grosso modo plutôt sur
la position qui consiste à dire
l'identité européenne ça n'est pas qu'un
prétexte à la construction ça doit être
l'objet même de cette construction de
l'objet même de ce que l'europe doit
défendre et donc par conséquent et là il
peut essayer de je dirais de créer un
consensus mais un consensus qui n'ira à
mon sens pas très loin wimax les gagner
parce que les tchèques et les slovaques
qui sont toujours sur la ligne vise
grade c'est à dire non aux quotas et et
non à l'accueil de migrants dont on ne
veut pas exactement vous mais je crains
que il ya un peu de consensus sur ce sur
ceux ici parce que vous l'avez dit c'est
pas une grande réconciliation
ce qu'on vit actuellement c'est une
nouvelle contradiction emmanuel macron à
pousser comme ils le pouvaient une
logique binaire en disant qu'il y avait
d'un côté les pro européens de leur côté
les anti européens on voyait
effectivement le piège électoral dans
lequel il se mettait qui correspond à
rien parce que d'ailleurs toutes les
études montrent aujourd'hui que les gens
attendent non pas de savoir s'ils sont
pour ou contre l'europe mais quelle
europe
ils veulent je crois que ça doit être le
débat du projet européen et avec ce
déplacement et ce petit changement
tactique de la part des malades macron
on voit qu'il n'est même pas capable de
tenir cette orientation là cette
orientation là sur le long terme
mais vous me direz il avait fait la même
chose en france il avait joué
les progressistes face au populisme lors
de l'élection présidentielle ça
aboutisse parce qu'il a été élu il a été
élu et mène une politique aujourd'hui
qui est vécu comme une politique
libérale au jour par la majorité des
concitoyens
on voit aujourd'hui qu'il veut faire la
même chose au niveau européen ils se
rapprochent déjà de ceux qui ont les
positions on va dire peut-être pas les
plus progressistes comme vous l'avez dit
sur la question de la gestion des
migrants ou sur les questions sociales
parce que vous parlez des travailleurs
détachés tout à l'heure le compromis qui
était sorti du débat européen est un
compromis qui n'était pas parfait
puisque notamment sur la question des
transporteurs routiers
il n'y a rien qui a été fait et c'est
pourtant une question importante
alors je me tourne vers jérôme
sainte-marie pour peut-être défendre
emmanuel macron pas exactement leur
espèce mais puisque nous sommes soit au
figaro là il venait donc citer mao tsé
toung
le vent de l'est l'emportent sur le mont
de l'ouest est effectivement là le vent
de l'est depuis l'élection du manioc de
macron a soufflé très fort c'est à dire
que d'un point de vue politique la
situation les manuels macro on n'est
plus tout la même que s'il avait fait
cette visite est un peu plus d'un an il
est aussi aujourd'hui à présent la
république qui est très affaibli dans
l'opinion parce que c'est ma partisans à
parler un tout petit peu alors même que
les régimes qui sont souvent libéraux à
l'intérieur de leurs frontières
sans être pour autant à professer une
idéologie si vous voulez comment
dirais-je du mondialiste sont un peu
connoté interrelations est aussi en tout
cas je sais pas fédéraliste on va dire
eh bien ces pays n'a bénéficié d'un
gouvernement dans ces pays là
bénéficient souvent d'un très fort
soutien de leurs opinions publiques sur
un fond justement de libéralisme interne
mais le nationalisme très fort articulé
bien sûr sur la question migratoire en
priorité de ce point de vue là l'italie
est en train de devenir un pays de l'est
si j'ose dire et vous avez bien là
dessus par rapport aux prochaines
élections européennes
on voit le cac 40 est emmanuel macron on
n'a jamais été aussi loin si vous voulez
de l'idée de départ d'emmanuel macron
d'être à la fois le porteur d'une
nouvelle de l'idée européenne en france
le garant d'un nul
nous attache avec l'union européenne en
france mais être également en europe le
garant de le porter de nouvelles paroles
françaises pour une europe plus
fédéraliste géré le rapport de forces au
niveau européen s'est complètement
effondrée et surtout il y avait un
argument très fort pour les élections
européennes qui est en train de
disparaître c'est la possibilité qu
aurait eu emmanuel macron affaires du en
marche au niveau européen
et là on sait plus très bien avec quel
groupe est la réplique en marche
pourrait s'intégrer on va dire surtout
quand vous regardez les prises de
position du gouvernement français c'est
à dire que sur toute une série de sujets
qui émergent
on a parlé des migrants et on a eu ces
derniers mois quelques épisodes on peut
parler de la directive femme homme sur
lequel le gouvernement s'est opposé
on voit bien que cette position qui
était on va dire très pro-européenne
finalement s'effrite à chaque fois qu'il
ya des vrais sujets et la promesse
macron d'être européen pour l'europe ne
tient pas en réalité comme bernard qui
va t-il rester alors comme pro européen
si monsieur mac ronces mais sur la ligne
du groupe devise grade madame merkel
n'est pas très en forme
je suis pas sûr quand même qu'il
devienne anti européen parce que ils
essayent je verrai de de créer des des
convergences pour pour constituer à
terme effectivement des groupes des
groupes au parlement européen
en revanche il est certain que la la
construction européenne est un nouveau
tournant il est certain que jusqu'à
présent l'opposition je dirai où la
critique de l'union européenne se
faisait essentiellement par un discours
hostiles à la construction européenne
et on peut peut-être envisager que avec
des prises de pouvoir dans un certain
nombre d'états par des courants
politiques convergent sur je dirais des
questions centrales liée à la
civilisation à l'identité à
l'immigration que eh bien ce soit non
pas en détruisant ou en démantelant de
l'union européenne mais en la
réorientant autrement que eh bien ces
courants politiques la chercheront à
voir de l' influence donc là de ce point
de vue là
ça sera intéressant de voir si je dirais
le souverainisme qui avaient émergé dans
les années 90 au moment je dirais de
l'approfondissement institutionnels et
de l'élargissement géographique si ce
souverainisme reste le porte étendard
je dirais des courant contestataire ou
si c'est courant contestataire prennent
un autre un autre drapeau ça sera généré
instructif de le voir en tout cas nos
internautes comprennent pas très bien ce
qui se passe un peu que nous non plus
d'ailleurs
cameroun eto'o qui nous dit emmanuel
macron fait de la politique quitte à ne
pas être cohérent olympe s'interroge
mais s'il n'y a pas de division alors
pourquoi il va t'il et monsieur babineau
nous dit c'est un coup de com encore une
fois macron est isolé et il projette
l'image d'un rassembleur ce qu'il n'est
pas peut-être aussi jérôme sainte marie
se dit il que en france sans son choix
d'opposer ces deux camps pour les
européennes pourraient se retourner
contre lui c'est à dire que le camp du
progrès finalement n'est pas aussi
attirant dans l'opinion que ce qu'ils
imaginent pour les européennes
ou alors je parle sous notre contrôle
mais il m'a semblé qu'il ya samedi
dernier il y avait eu une réunion de la
république en marche pour avec la
fondation jean jaurès notamment pour
pouvoir mettre en avant une forme pour
donner une doctrine en quelque sorte la
réplique en marche autour de la notion
de progressisme cette notion
progressisme est ce qu'on prend en
elle-même mais je comprends surtout en
opposition et c'est là où il ya un petit
tour de passe passe parce que sémantique
manquer ce qui est contre le projet 6
mhz c'est la réaction ou bien le
conservatisme mais là c'est pas
exactement ce que dit la réplique en
marche emmanuel macron depuis des mois
depuis les des années et ses
prédécesseurs en réalité de la deuxième
gauche
eux ils opposent la le progressisme au
nationalisme ya pas de rapport logique
vous voyez ce n'est pas de rapport c'est
un tour de passe passe assez étonnant et
donc c'est les progressistes qui sont
donc en quelque sorte pour un
dépassement des frontières au minimum
dans le cadre européen contre les
nationalistes qui eux sont les forces de
du passé mais là où ça devient
problématique c'est que ces formes ce
nationalisme vu comme une force de
passer c'est une idée qui est totalement
démenti je reviens dans mon intervention
précédente qui est totalement démentie
par le fait qu'aujourd'hui c'est bien
les courants nationalistes qui non
seulement qui depuis l'est mais de plus
en plus dans toute l'europe et bien
s'imposent comme les forces
dynamique en tout cas d'un point de vue
électoral maxime d'égayer vos amis
socialistes ils ont l'air un peu perdu
dans ce débat on les centres a pas
beaucoup alors c'est vrai qu'il ya pas
de têtes de listes pour les européennes
ce sera peut-être ségolène royal qui
sait mais il y à il ya eu un point de
vue socialiste là dessus ils sont plutôt
bas cronje j'imagine les socialistes non
non l'accord échappée qui est normal et
c'est ce ne sont pas ma cronje et chaque
jour qui passe ils le sont d'autant
moins comme les français d'ailleurs sur
la tête de lit je vous rassure nous
aurons une tête de liste mais nous avons
une procédure et nous avons fixé un
calendrier nous allons essayer de nous y
tenir je sais que c'est rare mais nous
allons essayer de le faire enfin sur ce
que vous évoquez sur notre position
d'opposition elle est assez clair c'est
qu'aujourd'hui on réfute
on n'est pas les seuls d'ailleurs le
j'ai vu que le modem était intervenue
récemment pour dénoncer aussi ce piège
européen qui viserait à dire que
l'élection européenne se jouera entre
deux camps seulement le camp de ceux qui
sont pour l'europe et ceux qui sont
contre l'europe
nous nous avons une vision différente
nous pensons qu'il faut poser la
question de ce qu'est l'europe nous
voulons qu'il faut faire preuve de
volontarisme et c'est pour ça d'ailleurs
que nous avons adopté un texte à
l'unanimité qui fixe nos priorités pour
une europe qui soit tout à la fois
sociales qu'ils fassent preuve de
volontarisme
on a parlé tout tarder à la question
industrielle le sujet aujourd'hui qui
est posée c'est ce que l'europe est
capable de pouvoir porter une stratégie
industrielle notamment sur en s'appuyant
sur la transition écologique
je crois pour ma part qu'on ne pourra
pas réconcilier les citoyens européens
avec l'europe
si celle ci n'apparaît pas comme étant
une solution à leurs problèmes allez-y
en suisse c'est que si vous faites j'ai
pas de conseillers vous donner mais si
vous faites une nouvelle fois campagne
sur la notion d'europe sociale c'est
totalement anachronique et
contreproductif
d'une part parce que ça a été fait à
chaque campagne européenne je peux vous
sortir les affiches avec dsk
prenant à l'europe sociale etc c'est
toute une collection chez moi c'est très
drôle mais vous n'avez également le fait
que vient ce nom vous dit que vous avez
le dossier vous avez évoqué de thaler
via notre par exemple les travailleurs
détachés
les français ont compris ou en tout cas
pense peut-être à tort que l'europe
sociale ne peut être ne peut se
construire que par l'abaissement
justement des conditions sociales en
france et une europe antisociales
non c'est pas ça mais appartement où
s'est nivelé avec des pays notamment à
l'est qui n'ont pas du tout
le même niveau de rémunération à des
protections sociales
on ne voit pas comment une europe
sociale pourrait être je fais autre
chose et vous assurer qu'un défaut pour
rassurer gm à la règle qui n'aimerait
pas que le parti socialiste face au
contraire ferrand ça c'est une bonne on
parle d'ailleurs je veux que tout le
monde je vous en remercie et je le note
non rassurez vous on fera pas une
campagne sur il faut une europe sociale
en sautant sur un tabouret et notre
sujet aujourd'hui c'est est ce qu'on
peut avoir une europe de gauche c'est à
dire que il ya d'aidé aux roms qui
peuvent être différentes
il ya toute une série de choix qu'on a
évoqué la question de la transition
écologique la question sociale la
question évidemment de la gestion des
migrants il ya plusieurs façons de
pouvoir y répondre
et donc il faut qu'ils aient ce grand
débat européen nous nous voulons
politisé l'europe et en faire un outil
au service des citoyens c'est pas simple
parce qu'aujourd'hui il ya évidemment
une défiance importante mais nous
croyons que ce n'est pas en posant le
pour ou contre l'europe que nous
pourrons rétablir de la confiance il
faut au contraire que nous démontrions
que l'europe est un instrument pour les
citoyens et là dessus que nous engageant
merci simplement je pense qu'il faut
éviter aussi me semble-t-il de confondre
l'europe avec l'union européenne
et ça je crains que dans les opinions
publiques et en particulier à l'est
il y est je dirais ce souhait
qu'effectivement on assimile pas
nécessairement les deux l'union
européenne peut être au service de
l'europe mais elle n'est pas la seule
incarnation de langues
une fois de plus peut-être en a fait un
mois l'occurrence la 7e vote pour le
parquet telles que l'union européenne
une autre europe est possible peut-être
0 ap 2 ans ancien on revient en france
on revient en france pour parler des
suites des affaires qui ont défrayé les
médias sur la violence à l'école un
certain nombre de propositions arrivent
il y avait une réunion ce matin de trois
ministres la garde des sceaux nicole
belloubet le ministre de l'intérieur
christophe castaner et jean michel
blanquer
son collègue de l'éducation nationale et
ils ont eu une idée
c'est christophe castaner qui la dévoile
tout de suite c'est mettre des policiers
dans les écoles dans les quartiers les
plus difficiles je pense en particulier
au quartier de reconquête républicaine
je n'exclus pas la possibilité de
présence à des moments de
attention particulière dans la journée
de présence physique de forces de
l'ordre dans l'établissement évidemment
mais nathan said accord des chefs
d'établissement qui les a utilisés pour
continuer ce qu'ils savent qu'à la
mairie garder la bonne idée c'est quand
même d'avoir réagi vite et de pas avoir
tergiversé dimanche dernier c'est à ces
femmes est raconte sur le la mettre au
compte de monsieur blanc caire qui n'a
pas minimisé a pas essayé de mettre la
chose poussière sous le tapis c'est
c'est d'une certaine manière sa marque
de fabrique depuis qu'il est au
gouvernement et c'est pour ça d'ailleurs
que dans les sondages depuis dans cette
série là où il est très apprécié après
ce que nous ne tournons un dossier à la
révolte des profs c1 et le corps
enseignant n'en peut plus de l'homme et
retard sur la question de la violence
des jeunes et la deuxième chose c'est
qu'on s'aperçoit que la violence des
années en train de muter serre que on a
moins des statistiques tu l'as pris ce
que nous avons trouvé montre que y est à
moins de délinquance juvénile mais en
revanche la violence est de plus en plus
importante je me faire lyncher rêvez de
vous reposer ma question mais peut-être
deux fois il répondait dans ces cas là
c'était c'est aussi un point de vue
faut-il ou non des policiers dans les
écoles est ce que ça vous choque au sein
de choc non ça me choque pas je pense
que le problème c'est de savoir si c est
ce que ce sera est ce que ce sera utile
par exemple l'inquiète qu'on a fait chez
les ch et les chez les pros chez
professeurs qui ont relayé ce que ce
hashtag c'est surtout que par exemple
ils sont confrontés un nombre d'injures
absolument incroyable série un
non-respect
est ce que les policiers vont faire
rater pas de hashtag tester les
policiers ont fait respecter ont réussi
à faire respecter les enseignants mais
ce n'est pas évident voilà on avait sur
la violence il faut savoir ce qu'on veut
on a un professeur autour de cette table
certes enseignement supérieur mais
guillaume bernard ya peut-être pas trop
de violence alice s en imaginant déjà
c'est une des raisons pour lesquelles j
suis d'ailleurs alors mais ça vous
empêche pas d'avoir un point de vue sur
ce sujet je suis effaré moi j'avoue que
les policiers dans un établissement
scolaire
vous m'aviez posé la question je m'en
souviendrai propos justement je dirais
de l' occupation de tolbiac et serra et
vit à envoyer les forces de l'ordre
peut-être pour déloger les personnes qui
bloquaient mais l'idée même qu'il y est
je dirais des forces de l'ordre dans un
lieu où on est là pour transmettre des
connaissances et le savoir alors moi
j'avoue sincèrement que
je veux bien apparaître comme étant un
peu anarchiste pour une fois mais là ça
non mais sincèrement sincèrement qu'elle
a veut dire que la solution pour
résoudre le problème de l'éducation des
enfants
c'est le fait de mettre des policiers
dans des écoles ça veut dire que les
enseignants n'ont plus d'autorité
ça veut dire que les parents ont mal
élevés je suis obligé on est obligé de
le reconnaître ont mal élever leurs
enfants
et ça veut dire que le lieu de la
transmission du savoir devient a lieu de
correction honnêtement trouvez moi une
autre solution
l'évadé policiers dont exemple les
parents va revenir dans un instant mais
on continue sur les profs on vous pose
la question sur twitter êtes vous pour
la présence de policiers dans les
établissements scolaires ce qui est
intéressant c'est que nos internautes
majoritairement pense comme vous
guillaume bernard à 60 % alors même
qu'on va dire que en général les
internautes qui suivent points de vue
sont plutôt favorables à une forme de
fermeté ce qui prouve que le sujet est
compliqué mais la fermeté elle doit
avoir lieu à ibb et pas comme ça oui je
on a compris jérôme sainte-marie
défendent la même position que guillaume
bernard je suis très influençable mais
d'un point de vue un peu différent d'un
point de vue un peu différents cirques
effectivement la réaction qu'on a à côte
ou qu'on a qu'on a heureusement pas vos
internautes mais qu'on les opinions a
souvent dans ce cas dire par apprendre
renvoyer la police et pourquoi pas
l'armée ensuite les tanks mais gérard
c'est en cela ce genre de rhétorique eu
facile mais qui cache effectivement le
caractère ahurissant de ce qui se passe
et notamment chacun à noter que le
c'était surtout on est confronté à des
stratégies d'évitement dans les
établissements scolaires où
effectivement le même les professeurs
finalement ben moi j'en sais j'enseigne
à dauphine n'est pas le genre de
problème mais il m'est arrivé à
intervenir dans des lycées dans les
établissements scolaires de cinq femmes
de temps en temps effectivement on sait
très bien que visiblement il est un
endroit où il ya une stratégie
d'évitement forcé des professeurs c'est
pas seulement lié je décèle de dire si
je te fais contre courant je pense de
votre audience de votre public mais je
pense que ce n'est pas uniquement lié à
des problèmes d'éducation
d'ailleurs les lycéens dont on parle
c'est son père qui lui la fonctionnelle
a ramené la mener à la police s'est pas
uniquement lié donc après des problèmes
moraux d'éducation la famille ou le
comportement des professeurs c'est aussi
lié à des phénomènes de ségrégation
sociale qui sont directement et là
monsieur guillaume bernard ne va pas
livres liés à la concurrence entre le
système privé et le système public dans
la banlieue francs notamment la région
parisienne ou là de fait vous avez moi
j'aurai encore une fois je travaille
dans a beaucoup dans les communes de la
banlieue parisienne
vous avez effectivement des
établissements qui sont catholiques
formellement mais ce n'est pas le sujet
pour les gens où vont tous les étudiants
tous les élèves qui sont souvent donc
d'origine européenne et à côté vous avez
des lycées qui sont des établissements
scolaires où il regroupe les gens comme
on dit maintenant de jalousie présente
sacré déféré le terrible rétablir
l'ordre dans ces établissements
c'est pas par racisme que les parents
veulent pas que leurs enfants soient
dedans c'est parce que ils veulent que
leurs enfants aux étudiants calme le
problème n'est pas là si vous avez deux
secte de deux systèmes qui sont en
concurrence déloyale et que deux fêtes
vous créez des aspects je ne veux pas ça
va vous sortir le trou dame est cité
sociale mais la non mixité sociale
absolue provoque des phénomènes qu'on
peut pas dont on ne peut pas s'abstraire
on va écouter maxime des gayets de même
si je suis minoritaire voire isolé
autour de cette table moi je pense que
s'il n'y a pas d'autre solution et ben
envoyons des policiers parce que de
toute évidence les profs n'arrive pas à
faire régner la discipline par eux mêmes
maxime dégage beaucoup d'arguments qui
ont été évoqués
dans le sens de ce que je pense donc je
vais pas les répéter d'abord indiqué que
quand vous avez cinq enfants turbulents
ou quand vous avez une classe sur blanc
que c'est pas la même chose donc
évidemment que la question de la mixité
sociale et envoie des turbulences et
même si on est on est tout à fait
d'accord sauf qu'on voit aussi que il
est évoqué dans la discussion qu'on a
eue il faut pas il faut pas se voiler la
face et on parle des insultes et puis on
parle aussi des des sujets des
agressions la plus grave donc dès qu'on
parle de ça on voit qu'il ya quand même
on va dire un nuage globale qui qui pose
la question des rapports et de
l'accompagnement des jeunes
je pense d'autre part que évidemment que
ça ne peut pas être en mettant des un
policier derrière chaque élève qu'on
réglera ce problème d'abord parce que ce
n'est pas le rôle de l'école vous l'avez
évoqué
deuxièmement parce que je pense en plus
que ce n'est pas le rôle des policiers
c'est à dire que dire aux policiers
maintenant vous allez devoir
faire régner l'ordre dans les
établissements vient posons leur aussi
la question ce n'est pas ce qu'attendent
les profs est en réalité moi ce qui me
qui me gêne un peu c'est que ce qui
manque aujourd'hui c'est évidemment
d'avoir plus de personnels adultes dans
les établissements et notamment dans les
établissements les plus en difficulté
ben on a supprimé deux mille postes
cette année on va en supprimer 4000
l'année prochaine donc je suis pas
certain que ça puisse nous permettre d'y
répondre
et il ya d'autres sujets qu'on évoque
peu qu'ils sont des questions d'ordre de
suivi psychologique parce que je crois
aussi que la question de la violence ou
des comportements
elle est liée aussi à une société qu une
société violente par les réseaux sociaux
par une évolution qui peut être
problématique est aujourd'hui sans je le
regarde pas il me semble que c'est
pourtant un vrai sujet de débat qu'on
évoque malheureusement que quand il ya
des faits divers j'ajoute parce qu'elle
est parce qu elle est d'accord avec ce
point de vue qui est celui de claire des
villes qui est l'une des dirigeantes du
snes le snes et le principal syndicat de
professeurs de l'enseignement secondaire
et elle dit on va criminaliser les
incivilités et des violences qui devrait
être réglé par la communauté éducative
donc je suis minoritaire mais c'est pas
grave je voudrais qu'on aborde un autre
point de ceux de ce dossier qui est la
responsabilité des parents on l'a évoqué
brièvement écouter ce témoignage de
rachida dati qui était ce matin chez nos
confrères d'rtl
elle a été bien sûr mais ni de la
justice mais elle a aussi été magistrate
et notamment au tribunal pour enfants de
bobigny et voilà un de ses souvenirs
je vous donnais juste cet exemple ça
m'est arrivé de faire comparaître des
mineurs qui avaient des commis des actes
graves et les parents ne viennent pas
oui ils sont envoyés avec un frère ou un
voisin hé ben non
les parents doivent être responsables
aussi de leurs enfants
c'est aussi de la faute des parents ce
qui arrive hervé nathan je moi j'ai la
fota je vais essayer d'éviter parce que
pour le coup c'est d'un soin des gens
qui sont les situations sociales
quelquefois très compliqué c'est sympa
de chance en revanche je voudrais juste
cité le témoignage d'un autre juge qui a
été juge pour enfants de monsieur euro
c'est ce que nous avons recueillies dans
le dossier que qui était d'ailleurs le
patron grâce erratique au tribunal pour
enfants drumel pour un produit
il a l'air il alerte dans marianne sur
le fait que souvent c'est des familles
monoparentales à redon qui est un beau
père il ya plus de père donc c'est des
garçons souvent la plupart du temps
c'est des garçons qui sont en cause qui
se retrouve avec ne plus avoir de père
la maison mais vous mais éventuellement
un compagnon de leur mère et il n'y a
aucun statut pour ce 7 autres adultes
qui pourraient faire fonction de deux
beaux pères ni faut un statut des beaux
parents il a demandé à plusieurs
reprises auprès de plusieurs
gouvernements il a jamais été suivis ni
à gauche ni à droite
c'est ces enfants là ils ont besoin d'un
cadre familial et la société doit le
leur donner et ça ils plaidaient pour ça
ils disent et donc du cerveau éviterait
peut-être de se retrouver en situation à
laquelle été rachetée avec des enfants
qui viennent qui comparaît seul ça c'est
sûr que c'est c'est us et 1 c'est
dramatique
guillaume bernard on peut encore
responsabilité responsabiliser alors les
parents ou la mère parce que souvent
c'est des familles qu'on appelle
pudiquement monoparentales par exemple
il ya des responsables de droite qui
disent on devrait supprimer les
allocations familiales pour ces familles
où les mineurs sont récidivistes
et là pour le coup il ya une majorité de
français qui est d'accord avec cette
proposition c'est un sondage au doxa
pour le figaro d'aujourd'hui
69% des français interrogés souhaitent
une mise en place mise en place de
sanctions financières pour les parents
d'élèves violence n'est pas la même
selon mme bernard parce que les
allocations familiales ont un but en
faveur de la natalité de la démographie
c'est pas une mesure
comment dire c'est pas une mesure
sociale dans le but de rééquilibrer les
choses
c'est dans le but de la natalité c'est
pour aider les familles en revanche de
sanctionner
et c'est là où on sait là on en arrive
au problème est donc sanctionné des
faits des actes qui sont effectivement
intolérable ça oui
et se pose la question et pardon de
revenir un tout petit peu en arrière
mais ça me permet de répondre à votre
question c'est toujours le même problème
en criminologie il ya deux grandes
explications du passage à l'acte
il ya ceux qui nous expliquent que le
passage à l'acte est due à la situation
d'inégalité de celui qui va commettre
l'infraction est ce qu il avait dit
aussi bon et puis il y a l'explication
du passage à l'acte en raison de la
vulnérabilité et de là comment dire
proximité je dirais de la victime est
donc dans ce cas là l'explication du
passage à l'acte pardon d'y revenir
c'est évidemment le fait qu' il y a un
manque d'adéquation morales culturelles
ou le fait de se sentir
je dirais appartenir au corps social
suffisamment pour justement respecter
les règles les tabous les non-dits de ce
corps social là donc moi je suis au
regret de dire que je ne souhaite pas
qu'il y ait des forces de l'ordre dans
les établissements scolaires et encore
moins dans les universités qui sont des
lieux de recherche scientifique
mais il est bien évident que en revanche
les actes qui sont commis et qui sont
des actes de délinquance ou du moins
d'incivilités mais voilà on a quand même
avec les exemples récents vu qu'il
s'agit beaucoup plus véritablement de
délinquance que de simples la civilité
cela doivent être sanctionnés et
sanctionner durement quelques points de
vue d'internautes vicky qui nous dit ça
va créer un climat d'angoissé pour les
enfants qui se poseront la question
pourquoi la police était là je suis en
danger
pierre aussi est plutôt opposés à cette
présence des policiers dans les
établissements scolaires ce genre de
proposition est catastrophique et montre
que le gouvernement n'a rien compris au
canada de cette situation qui dure
depuis 20 ans si je nous dit un gamin de
16 ans qui est nul à l'école serait
mieux dans un atelier apprendre un
métier ça c'est tout le sujet de
l'apprentissage et monsieur babineau
complète complète ce que disait jérôme
sainte marie
le déséquilibre du manque de moyen
comparé à d'autres établissements
est-ce qu'on en parle maxime d'égailler
non c'est vrai vous parliez de la
concurrence de la sélection des élèves
qui fait qu'à un moment donné entre les
vlp le travail des professeurs devient
pratiquement impossible quand vous avez
uniquement des ans des gens qui sont
issus de familles en difficulté sociale
ou pour toute autre raison
et bien pour compris pour l'heure
d'ailleurs leur appartenance culturelle
ou te le fait qu'il ya plus de corse
culturel et social commun quelle que
soit et pas ils n'ont pas stigmatisation
de telle ou telle culture sur le fait
qu'il ya plus de normes communes
et bien c'est beaucoup plus important
que le manque de moyens d'autant plus
rien juste par là je vais dans des
établissements de seine-saint-denis
faut quand même pas exagérer les choses
l'état investit énormément
sauf que comme une arène mais sauf que
la composition même si vous voulez du
corps pas dupe a dépanné pas les profs
sont formés mais c'est surtout le fait
qu' il ya une population d'élèves qui ne
sont plus difficilement gérable maxime
résume juste en deux mois les
interventions précédentes
en gros il ya un problème culturel en
particulier avec les enfants issus de
l'immigration met les pieds dans le plat
sauf que j'espérais que ça n'était pas
je n'espérais que c'était passé conclut
à cette conclusion nous allions arriver
je ne pense pas je pense que le problème
aujourd'hui je reprends ce que dit
jérôme sainte marie
il ya eu un rapport qui vient de sortir
sur les collèges francilien où on voit
qu'il ya des inégalités qui sont
incroyables gère le le taux de réussite
au brevet il passe du simple au double
suivant suivant l'établissement
et quand vous regardez par exemple la
question des enseignants vous apercevez
que les enseignants qui sont les plus
confirmés sont évidemment dans les
endroits qui sont les endroits dans
lequel les conditions de travail on va
dire sont les plus simples et que par
contre on en voit dans les quartiers les
plus difficiles les enseignants qui
sortent à peine encore à quelle dans
lequel il ya beaucoup de turnover etc
etc
la difficulté que nous avons aujourd'hui
il faut le reconnaître c'est que nous
avons un système qui reproduit
d'inégalités et moi je crois que c'est
d'abord en essayant de permettre à
chacun de pouvoir réussir que nous
pourrons nous sortir de cette situation
et encore une fois regardons aussi ce
que disent les profs les profs ils ne
veulent pas de policiers et ce qu'ils
veulent c'est à voir
être plus nombreux dans les
établissements pour pouvoir mieux suivre
les enfants
je sais peut-être moins clinquant que
d'essayer de lier ces problématiques ou
à des sujets culturels ou à des coups de
menton sécuritaires moment il me semble
qu'il faut et bien mettre les moyens sur
l'éducation pour pour faire en sorte
qu'elle joue pleinement son rôle
il nous reste quelques minutes pour
traiter un sujet plus léger heureusement
le week end arrive vous avez peut-être
suivi ce bras de fer autour du loto du
patrimoine alors je rappel des épisodes
précédents
stéphane baert propose une loterie
spécifique pour le patrimoine organisées
par la française des jeux
ça rapporte pas mal d'argent la plupart
des fonds vont vers les gagnants il ya
20 millions d'euros pour le patrimoine
pour restaurer des monuments historiques
en danger et puis on apprend que il ya
14 millions que l'état se met dans la
poche et c'est normal parce que
s'appelle les taxes que voulez vous on
est en france
sauf que ça ça plaît pas du tout à
stéphane bern et donc stéphane bern a
dit je ne céderai pas je veux que tout
l'argent soit pour la loterie et il a
obtenu raison contre gérald darmanin le
ministre du budget grâce au soutien de
franck riester et même des manuels macro
et stéphane bern il est assez content
d'avoir gagné la partie hier 7 du jeu et
il ya les taxes elles sont touchées par
les appels à manifester comme beaucoup
de français la colère et donc j'ai
demandé aux ministres de revoir de
trouver une solution j'ai utilisé cette
notoriété qui la mienne pour servir une
cause qui est aussi la mienne celle du
patrimoine je n'ai pas de parti
mon seul parti c'est le parti du
patrimoine mais je remercie musela
cutter avoir fait son travail
merveilleusement bien et surtout le
président a entendu ma mamma voit aussi
il a compris on peut pas me confier une
mission et ensuite me mettre en
permanence des bâtons dans les roues
à la fin il faudrait plus de stéphane
bern non c'est sûr mais on n'apprend
rien personne une certaine manière ils
étaient unanimes ils avaient de levier
le premier c'est qu'effectivement on
pouvait pas lui faire deux fois le coup
de la loi est lancé dans la loi est lent
on a supprimé la protection des
monuments aux fins de l'environnement
des monuments historiques parlée par les
architectes des bâtiments et des
bâtiments de france
il était furieux et avec raison
d'ailleurs mais c'est quand même passé
et là il a saisi l'occasion que du fait
qu'ils avaient à nouveau mise la culture
qui lui avait sans doute plus de poids
en tout cas pouvait pas désavoué au
quasiment huit jours seulement après sa
nomination en disant qu'ils comptent
pour rien dégage
dégage de là et donc il a obtenu
finalement va me 21 millions d'euros
bravo c'était plusieurs vues il a su
attendre son heure
et ça c'est pour albi c'est très très
fort en vous êtes assez assez presque
unanime plus des trois quarts pour
trouver que l'état devrait subventionner
plus largement le patrimoine français
maxime de gagner une des leçons de cette
histoire c'est que dans ce pays a trop
de taxes quoi en gros l'état lève des
impôts partout alors la première leçon
de cette histoire c'est que j'aurai
j'aurais aimé que stéphane bern
justement qu'il y en ait plus notamment
pour récupérer les 40 millions d'euros
que le gouvernement à sucre et aux
agriculteurs notamment sur la question
de l'exonération des charges pour les
travailleurs saisonniers mais raillée
notre mba
on est malheureusement comme il nous
reste à plus de trois minutes on va
devoir rester concentrer sur les vrais
plus sérieusement c'est vrai c'est une
bonne chose mais c'est fin c'est une
bonne chose ça ne pouvait que se
terminer comme ce que comme ça pour une
raison simple c'est que de toute façon
les 250 projets qui devait être financé
sa nécessité au moins 50 millions
d'euros
donc il y avait un problème de moyens
c'est aujourd'hui le budget du
patrimoine ces 300 millions d'euros il
ya des manques évidents et là encore il
n'y a pas de politique qui est menée de
manière volontariste sur le sujet il n'y
aura donc d'ailleurs pas assez d'argent
avec cette loterie du patrimoine
ce qu'il faudrait en réalité c'est
réfléchir à d'autres levier jeu on peut
notamment penser à la taxe de séjour qui
permettrait et parce qu'il ya un rapport
excellent de la fondation jean jaurès
sur le sujet qui permettrait pouvoir
financer même niveau oui mais oui alors
vous devriez contentieux parce qu'on
ferait payer je ne revends la soirée tic
à la fois les touristes français mais
aussi étrangers et ça semblerait logique
pour pouvoir entretenir notre patrimoine
jérôme sainte-marie très vite faire le
pont avec le début de l'émission sur le
progressisme on a le problème alors je
marche un peu sur les plates-bandes de
mon nom de guillaume bernard mais on a
le problème ça quand vous avez une
explication dans le maquereau nisme du
progressisme à la croissance économique
et donc effectivement peut-être que le
patrimoine c'est pas très bon pour la
croissance économique peut-être que la
loi est la raison si on construit des
trucs à côté etc on fout tout en l'air
eh bien peut-être que ce sera très bon
pour la croissance là c'est un choix de
société extrêmement grave et
malheureusement je pense que
effectivement la macro ni ses loisirs de
maquereaux nisme comme idéologie est une
idéologie qui est encore une fois sur le
rendement du capital et qui ne
souhaitent plus tôt
ici effectivement on peut se passer le
patrimoine une variable d'ajustement
mais n'est pas un bien immatériel à
préserver en serait le mot de la fin ça
montre emmanuel macron quand même
quelqu'un de complexe parce que d'un
côté il est dans le camp du progressisme
et c est en même temps là il donne
raison à berne en dix ans les monuments
historiques les racines et traditions
est important non écoutez moi moi j'aime
bien malgré ses attaches orléaniste et
j'aime billets beaucoup stéphane bern
mais il est bien évident que parce qu'il
n'est pas très révolutionnaire comme vu
dans l'histoire même je serai je serai
je serais même attaché je dirais à des
branches plus ancienne mais le problème
de stéphane bern si vous voulez c'est
que il sert de faire-valoir
c'est un épouvantail pour dire on
protège le patrimoine
il me semble quand même que lorsque l'on
réforme ligue sf que l'on exclut de liez
f
un certain nombre je dirais de produits
financiers et qu'en revanche son
maintien zoubir et l'immobilier dans l'
isf il bien évident qu'on ne participe
pas de la défense du patrimoine parce
que le patrimoine c'est pas que des
bâtiments publics
c'est aussi tous les propriétaires
privés qui essayent de maintenir le
tissu social les bien tu dirais de nos
provinces et là cela ils ne sont
absolument pas aidé et donc par
conséquent et donc voilà je me crois
qu'il n'y a plus sa place pour un
discours un discours sur la question je
dirais de la défense du patrimoine
beaucoup plus que tu dirais la défense
réelle
je verrai du mathier la défense réelle
et le maintien je dirais du patrimoine
commun qui appartient et à la puissance
publique mais aussi aux propriétaires
privés
décidément il n'est pas facile en ce
moment d'être macro disent merci
beaucoup à tous les quatre points de vue
c'est terminé pour ce soir mais on se
retrouve lundi prochain j'aurai le
bonheur d'être à ce micro si vous
daignez vous connecter à leur habituelle
c'est-à-dire 17h merci beaucoup et bon
week end
[Musique]